[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm der mcmahon and
you're watching sky news and a special
question and answer program on the war
in ukraine the headlines today turkey's
president brings together delegations
from ukraine and russia with both sides
making concessions towards peace
the most meaningful progress since the
beginning of negotiations was made today
we report from kiev's suburbs where
ukraine's forces are given a reprieve as
russians reduce military activity there
meanwhile in other areas fighting
continues with a strike in mikaela
reportedly killing at least seven people
[Music]
a very good evening well tonight we're
hoping to answer as many of your
questions as possible on day 34 of the
war in ukraine coming up in just a
moment i'll be joined by our security
and defense analyst michael clark and
get the latest on today's peace talks
but first let me bring you a summary of
the rest of the day's news today and the
metropolitan police have issued 20 fines
they say to people who attended lockdown
breaking parties across whitehall
including at number 10 downing street
it's not yet known who the fixed penalty
notices have been given to or which
events they relate to a spokesman for
the prime minister mr johnson said he
hadn't received a fine at this time but
said number 10 will make it public if he
does
the boss of piano ferries has rejected
the government's demand to re-hire 800
workers it sacked without notice the
chief executive peter hebelthwaite
insists that reversing that would cause
the company to collapse but he did
apologize for the impact his company's
actions had had on those employees
facing redundancy
the trial of an alleged member of an
islamic state group that beheaded
hostages in iraq and syria has begun
al-shafi al-shaikh part of the group
nicknamed the beatles by their captives
because of their british accents will be
put on trial in virginia in the united
states the trial is expected to last for
at least a month
the queen has led the royal family at a
memorial to her late husband the duke of
edinburgh at westminster abbey it's the
first public appearance that her majesty
has made in five months
well queen elizabeth was accompanied by
prince andrew in a clear sign of support
for her son after he paid millions of
pounds out in an out of court settlement
of a civil sexual assault case
well during the ceremony her majesty sat
alongside one of her other sons and her
heir of course prince charles and his
wife camilla
the service celebrated the life of the
duke attended by many members of the
royal family a dedication by the dean of
windsor back prince philip left many of
those in attendance including the queen
tearful
through his
passionate commitment
he drew others to himself
in admiration
and respect
and in the case of those who
lived and worked most closely to him
genuine love
well now uh let's uh bring you latest on
the war in ukraine and the latest round
of peace negotiations got underway in
istanbul today there was a hint of a
climb down perhaps by the russian side
which said it would dramatically reduce
military activity around the capital
kiev and the city of cherniv but one u.s
official cast doubt about a
de-escalation saying that russia was
just shifting gears our correspondent
alistair bunkel has the latest on the
talks
the magnificent dolma bache palace in
istanbul is just across the black sea
from ukraine and was the setting for
another round of peace talks they didn't
last long barely half a day but as they
broke up and news started to filter out
there were rumors of a breakthrough
ukraine said it won't give up any of its
territory but will give up its hopes of
joining nato
if we manage to secure these key
provisions ukraine will be able to
effectively cement its current status as
a non-block a non-nuclear state in the
form of permanent neutrality
crimea occupied by the russians since
2014 and the disputed donbass region
remain complicated issues to resolve
they've recognized crimea as part of
russia that's their right to speak about
it to fix their position like this but
the ukrainian position is clear it's not
under any discussion whatsoever
russia for its part is reportedly
dropping its aim of regime changing
ukraine and says it is prepared to scale
back the invasion
the ministry of defense of the russian
federation decided to fundamentally cut
back military activity in the direction
of kiev and chernahiv to increase mutual
trust and create the necessary
conditions for further negotiations
if that were to happen it would be hard
for moscow to spin it as anything other
than a humiliating retreat from a battle
they thought they would win in just a
matter of days
reading between the lines of statements
given to the media during peace talks is
always very tricky especially during
this conflict the russians have time and
time again
made promises and then broken them and
there are plenty of people here who
believe that all of this all of this
diplomacy is just a charade whilst
moscow regroups and goes at ukraine
again
but
the signs are positive concessions are
clearly being made on both sides it
could just be that the gap is narrowing
the turks who of course want to be the
peacemakers were cautious but revealed
the possible next steps
the most meaningful progress since the
beginning of negotiations was made today
the more difficult issues will be taken
up at a higher level
the presence of roman abramovich amid
the negotiators caught everyone's
attention he was looking perfectly
healthy after reports claimed the
oligarch and three ukrainian negotiators
had been poisoned in kiev a few weeks
ago
no date for further talks has been said
but if what we're told is to be believed
then the time could be nearing for
zolensky and putin to meet
alice the bunker sky news in istanbul
well let's get to your questions then
now hundreds of you have been sending in
questions for our security and defense
analyst professor michael clark who's
here with me once again you're very
welcome michael and a lot of questions
of course naturally on these peace
negotiations so let's get straight in
and get your take on how they may
progress and uh what may flow from it
this is the question to kick us off from
thomas saying can we trust a promise
from russia during these talks when
they've repeatedly shown themselves to
be
well that is that is the big question if
anything does result from these talks
any deal could you trust it well there'd
have to be a lot of uh verification and
a lot of checks um you know it was uh
president reagan who said we're dealing
with arms control in the russian she
said trust and verify in this case it
was an old russian proverb wasn't it
that he was that's right yeah trust him
very fast
exactly he said that's what we do we
trust and verify and in this case i
guess it would be distrust and double
check treble check it doesn't mean to
say that that any deal would be
completely worthless but it would mean
that it would have to be surrounded by
other checks because undoubtedly
president putin has used up the trust
that he may have had in the world
certainly with the western world by
lying and lying and lying about what his
intentions were he told everyone sort of
you know went on a path to moscow to
talk to him and he told everybody he
told macron at least three times i will
not invade ukraine then he invaded you
there are also a lot of previous deals
in place aren't there concerning ukraine
uh the the normandy process that's right
yeah the minsk minsk two yeah and the
normandy uh process which was uh france
and germany and russia and ukraine and
to be honest the ukrainians were the
ones who pulled away from that because
it was a lousy deal i mean neither side
observed it but it was a rotten deal for
ukraine and germany and france in a
sense pressured the ukrainians in order
to stop the war in 2014 and the
ukrainians never really had an interest
in pushing that forward and putin used
that to say well they're not pushing
forward i'm not going to push it forward
and there's you know any future deal
will have to look a bit different to the
minsk process
but i mean here's the thing that
everyone fears the americans have
articulated it for quite a long time now
that even if there is a deal signed and
sealed and some kind of withdrawal
certainly a ceasefire by the russians
don't both sides simply use it to re-arm
and prepare to go at it again no doubt
um the west nato countries would stuff
ukraine with even more high-tech armory
and and the russians would rebuild the
army i'm sure that that would happen
both sides need a break for different
reasons uh and the ukrainians certainly
would restock because you know history
has shown them that they can't trust
their neighbor not to invade them
in now three times in effect um and the
russians would certainly use a pause to
reposition army that's what the
americans have said today they said they
don't believe that this is a peace uh
feeler this is the russians actually
needing a pause to reorder their forces
that doesn't mean to say it's worthless
a lot of peace processes just start
small and gather a momentum and that's
what might be the case here so we've got
to get to a deal first then now we're
getting ahead of ourselves well annie
has been in touch now uh about some of
the positive noises coming out of these
peace talks in istanbul today but asks
uh is uh sorry this is linda um linda
says why should russia have any say in
what ukraine do or don't do
this this whole idea that you know this
is a sovereign nation
that's right and sovereignty is
guaranteed in the un charter ukraine is
a member of the un and famously um
article two paragraph one and article
two paragraph seven uh guarantee the
domestic jurisdiction of all powers all
powers are free to make their own
decisions article 51 says that all
powers are free to defend themselves
it's all there in the u.n charter
however
the reality of power politics is that if
you live close to a very strong neighbor
as the finns do as sweden does as
ukraine does as georgia does then you
have to sensibly have due regard to not
acting in a way that provokes a problem
with that neighbor so
of course ukraine has the sovereign
right to do what it wants but ukraine
will be well advised to think carefully
about its future because it is an
existential issue not people use the
phrase existential threat wrongly it's
not it's not a threat to your existence
an existential threat which is a threat
exists it is there that because of the
nature of the situation and it isn't the
nature of the situation
the nature of geography that ukraine
will live next to a very big russia so
it will always have to think about that
michael i want to put annie's question
to you we haven't been able to put it up
uh something went wrong with our graphic
sequence there but i i can read it out
it's very short but it's very important
and annie asks could the peace
negotiations really be concluded quickly
or will they go on for months or
possibly is and that's back to what
we've been talking about um you know
minsk and other agreements and uh
protocols on ukraine
i mean this idea we're getting a bit
excited about the noises coming out of
istanbul today i mean this clearly is
could be just the prelude to to months
and years it could
absolutely it could and president
zielenski has been really clever i mean
he you know he makes putin look really
flat-footed all the time because
zelensky is saying let's talk we've got
to talk you can't you can't carry on
fighting all the time and he says look
we're prepared to talk about neutrality
we're prepared to talk about
non-alignment we're prepared to talk
about uh demilitarization however he
says
any deal we do will have to be put to a
referendum and that will take some time
and i will want some security guarantees
if we agree to any of these things and
of course ukraine had security
guarantees in 1994 and those security
guarantees were from russia america and
britain when ukraine gave up the nuclear
weapons it had inherited from the old
soviet union so they had security
guarantees in 2014 one of those
guarantors attacked it and the other two
guarantors britain and america pretended
we'd never made those guarantees we just
sort of whistled in the air as if it was
nothing to do with us so the ukrainians
are very entitled to say look if you
want us to trust moscow again we want
pretty big security guarantees the only
security guarantee that would meet their
needs would be membership of nato which
gives them the article five guarantee
that an attack on one is an attack on
all and that's out of the question so
these negotiations put uh zielinski is
talking them up he's talking around them
and he's sounding very reasonable very
clever
the conditions that he is putting sound
reasonable they're almost impossible to
fulfill
and he's running rings around putin at
the moment by as it were creating these
ideas and it does mean that if they talk
the talking will go on for a very long
time unless or until the situation on
the ground changes but because ukraine
is doing well on the ground zolensky
feels strong enough to actually um take
the lead to be assertive to be proactive
putin we don't know what he thinks about
any of this yet okay well petra has a
question which throws into our
discussion the the other element of any
possible peace deal and uh you know it's
unclear what effect they're having on
the mind of president putin at the
moment and this is uh in the event of a
peace deal will the west lift the
sanctions imposed on russia and of
course you know the west's not taking
part in these talks they can't put that
on the table but presumably the the
russians would want to see a pretty
quick easing of them yes and always the
the ramping down of sanctions is always
an incentive on good behavior so what
the west might say separate to the talks
but complementary to them is of course
if there's a deal then we would look at
sanctions and we look at listening this
and this and this but the idea of taking
sanctions off altogether i think is not
realistic because remember president
putin has crossed a line here when he
invaded his neighbor this is the most
egregious use of force to change
boundaries since 1939 this is the
biggest european crisis since the second
world war in those terms
and there's no way back for putin from
this so even if the the west wants to
help to create the momentum towards a
peace deal it's not going to say okay
well as a deal now let's take the
sanctions off and all go back to normal
there will be no going back to normal
for europe after this and can i just ask
you though michael while we're talking
about sanctions
i mean clearly there's much talk about
unity by president biden and the west
but there's not unity is there an actual
fact there are different approaches and
sanctions from from different countries
particularly when it comes to to russian
gas we see that they made a record
amount of money out of it in in the last
month since the war started i noticed um
in terms of um in terms of the ruble
it's almost back to where it was against
the dollar and indeed the best
performing stock market in the last
month in the world is the russian one
because because it went way down that's
because it's it's the dead bounce yeah
if it falls far enough it bounces up but
it is about the effect of sanctions are
they really making the russians hurt
they are um because it's not just the
official sanctions it's the unofficial
sanctions the fact that russia is toxic
means that more firms are pulling out
heineken um big firm in russia they
pulled out yesterday and said that's it
we're not going to invest and we're
we're closing all of our outlets all
these things matter um
the thing about the sanctions i think is
that
they will affect russia and they will
affect this sense that russia has
crossed the line the russians don't
believe that because i'm not being told
that but it matters to everybody else
and so i think that the sanctions may
start to come off
but you know life is very different now
i mean we're in a new era since a month
ago okay uh question from susanna next
uh interesting question that uh suzanne
has got about nato we've just been
talking about that so the the ambition
that uh president zielenski seems to
have dropped for the time being if
ukraine agrees to neutrality in the
negotiations is it possible for them to
secretly join nato later i mean just
isn't that a bit of a problem in this
article five which means that if one's
attacked or attacked don't you have to
let would-be aggressors know about it
yes it's a deterrent i think susannah i
i can see what you're getting out there
but you can't join nato secretly if you
go to nato headquarters there are 30
flags arranged there there are 30
delegations they've all got 30 offices
there are 30 members of the na the north
atlantic council who meet as head of
state or foreign ministers or defense
ministers you can't do it secretly
secret negotiations got a very bad name
in the 19th century because there were
secret alliances
and that what they realized in the first
world war because of the outbreak of the
first world war is that concluding
secret deals is a really silly thing to
do because if you conclude analyze you
want the world to know about it so they
don't miscalculate
and so no you can't join nato secretly
nor should you be able to because nato
is a free
uh a free market liberal democratic
group
not not all liberal democrats in it but
in theory it's a liberal democratic
group of 30 nations who've met certain
conditions and are proud of the fact
that they form a collective defense
organization to look after each other
what about the eu because we are told
that the russians would countenance
ukraine minus whatever bits they would
keep joining the eu and of course it has
extensive defensive capabilities uh it
has some uh eu's defensive capabilities
only ever go up to sort of battlegroup
level the eu is okay for crisis
management but you wouldn't want to
fight a war with what the eu could
provide as the eu
the issue is not so much um
you know would ukraine be allowed to
join the eu one of the issues would the
eu have ukraine in politically they'd
like to but this is a big country with a
big agricultural sector it would not you
know knock seven bells out of the common
agricultural policy for instance uh as
it as it stands so there'll be a lot of
transition required but for political
reasons i mean ukraine could be put on
some sort of fast track to eu membership
and the other thing to remember that
even if ukraine doesn't join the eu and
nato um which it certainly won't join
nato that's not to say it can't get help
from those organizations and one of the
things that mr putin was so angry about
he said look ukraine isn't in nato but
nato certainly in ukraine you know look
at all the stuff that nato was doing in
ukraine and the answer is yes if you
hadn't invaded them in 2014 maybe they
wouldn't have asked for help in the way
that they did nato was helping them
because you
stole big pieces of their territory in
2014. okay michael we're going to change
tack in a moment but before that we're
we have to take a break you're watching
a special question and answer program on
the war in ukraine next we're asking
what weapons are the ukrainians still
looking for from the west stay with us
that'd be him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is
a lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's despite the victory
these students
and now they're going to be arrested
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark and your questions about the war
in ukraine so uh let's get right into it
again you ready michael uh richard wants
to know this uh what weapons or
equipment is the ukrainian army short of
well uh suspect that's a pretty long
list um what what do they need in
essence they they need more of
everything that they've used they need
more ammunition for everything which
means more stinger missiles more end
lore and javelin anti-tank weapons and
so on i mean britain has said that we've
given them 4 000 which is all of ours
our stocks and then some and there's
another 6 000 pieces on the way of
various things that we're acquiring to
give so britain's been very much in the
forefront of sending this sort of stuff
in the longer run what the ukrainians
need is not more of the same well they
do need more of the same but they also
need longer-range weapons if this war
for them purely in a military sense if
it's going to go on for a little while
then they need more missiles longer
range artillery they need to be able to
hold the russians at risk further away
than when they're actually fighting them
that's what the russians can do to the
european unions
they can hit them from further away the
ukrainians can't do that and given that
their air defense system is still up and
running
they would certainly welcome more
aircraft of all types mainly the su-24
not so much the mig-29s that everyone
talks about but ground attack aircraft
would be really quite useful for them
and of course i've got a question uh
about the equipment and the training
that's required for some of this very
high tech stuff now of course the west
has been training ukrainians in ukraine
yeah on the systems now presumably some
of that's taking place in poland but
it's it's a lot more difficult now it is
i mean the britain had trained under um
uh the operation they were doing before
was they trained 22 000 uh ukrainian
troops many of them trained in the
technical sides of the weapons that they
were using um the star streak system
that they're going to get now they need
a lot more training for that is that
they're going to try and push six months
of training into a few weeks and we'll
see how that really works but but
in one sense an army that's fighting a
war
picks it up very quickly because they
have to but in another sense it's quite
hard to withdraw people for long enough
to do the training reorganize and get
back into the battlefront so it is
difficult and people say oh you know
give ukrainians more weapons i mean
first of all getting them there is a
problem um you know sending them tanks
for instance there are 500 t-72 tanks in
nato countries that's the ukrainians
could do with them but the tank is even
the t-72 is 40-yard 45 tons it has to go
on the back of a truck
it's quite hard to do that secretly and
get them to where the ukrainians need
them which is in the east of the country
not the west where they come from
vulnerable getting them there i suppose
well michael has a question about uh the
big stuff uh the aircraft uh let's be
having you michael um
okay i'll read it out for you um oh
there we are
do the issues around supplying fighter
jets come down to the definition of
aggressive and defensive weapons is this
an excuse from nato countries but i
suppose when it comes to weaponry it uh
depends who's doing the attacking and
who's doing the defending they they can
be both absolutely right if you pick up
a chair to defend yourself against
somebody attacking you it's a defensive
weapon if you go and hit somebody over
the head with a chair it's an offensive
weapon it depends what you do with it
and it is the case i mean i i think you
know michael's point is a is a very good
one to raise
the the the question of aircraft is not
whether they're offensive or defensive
again you can use them either
defensively or offensively it was the
symbolism of aircraft that the russians
said we will regard this as a very
hostile act and nato particularly united
states at this stage backed off because
they thought it would be provocative as
the war goes on they may reconsider that
i mean i suspect that aircraft might be
given to the ukrainians if they could
find a good way to get them there at
some point in the future well the very
first time we did one of these i think
it was three weeks ago that was when
poland announced that it was giving some
of its uh migs to the ukrainians
through the americans through germany
that's right but that's never happened
there because
and that announcement came in about
three minutes before we did the program
and you you read it to me then and so it
hasn't happened but i wouldn't rule it
out because the you know the theory is
if if you need the aircraft and you use
them defensively that's absolutely fine
and there is no way there's no way that
ukraine is going to launch some sort of
offensive war against russia
they just won't so everything you give
the ukrainians will be used in this
essentially in a defensive context okay
another question this one coming in from
simon he says if russia carried out a
military strike on any embassy in
ukraine of a nato member accidentally or
indeed deliberately is that classed as
an attack on a nato country well the
embassies have been by large shut down
in kiev many of them moved to levive and
indeed outside the country but if they
were attacked by russia how would that
be regarded no i mean an embassy doesn't
count as an attack on your country your
embassy is a piece of sovereign
territory but it's there by grace of the
the host uh country so it's a diplomatic
arrangement and indeed i mean embassies
have been attacked and diplomats have
been killed all over the world it's one
of the um the dangers of being a
diplomat it's not regarded as an attack
on the homeland i remember the nato
operation uh concerning kosovo in serbia
in 1999 when they actually hit the
chinese chinese embassy they did there
was a moment where the the nato i mean
nato worked very hard in that campaign
to avoid civilian casualties and they
were dropping non-lethal weapons so they
were they were dropping weapons of
copper wire
on the um substations the electric
substance to turn the lights on off in
belgrade to prove they could do it but
there was a terrible
intelligence mistake and they bombed the
chinese embassy and there was a moment
where there were more chinese killed
than anybody else in kosovo in in serbia
in belgrade because of that the chinese
were furious but nothing followed
because that's what happens okay another
question on this uh section this one is
from sarah who asks well this is a very
interesting question sarah what happens
to russian troops who mutiny are they
still involved in the fighting because
we saw something on social media today
about uh a russian allegedly handing
over his tank and being given some money
for yeah seven hundred pounds
which presumably is a fair amount of
money um
although his tank commander had deserted
already gone off somewhere else so this
this lad found himself alone in his tank
and i think he thought well i'll take
the money and you know see what else
life holds for me mutiny is illegal in
every country and it's a very serious
offence and
i mean at one time it was just a
straight shooting offense simple as that
um nowadays in most militaries i think
in the russian military too it's it's a
it's a severe court martial and some
pretty severe penalties but mutiny comes
in all shapes and sizes so official
mutiny very very serious
the the lack of obeying orders
is a condition of military life or
obeying orders only a bit a bit
carefully i mean in any in any platoon
of say 25 people 25 men let's say some
some maybe women these days but
generally speaking 25 men and this goes
back you know 100 years of military
studies
five or six of them will be the natural
fighters they want to fight they're good
at it they enjoy it five or six of them
will be the ones who absolutely don't
want to fight and they will find any
excuse not to and the 15 in the middle
the 10 in the middle will be the ones
who will go with whichever is whichever
group is more dominant and so you find
that units will be ordered to do
something and they just kind of won't do
it or they'll be able to do something
and they'll do it and more because of
the attitude of that unit at any given
moment so mutiny
comes in lots of little gradations and
you can't often pin it on a soldier that
you did you disobeyed no sir i followed
orders but i was pinned down i couldn't
go any further it's fascinating about
the psychology i think sarah was also
asking are they still involved in the
fighting uh meaning you know have they
switched sides and are the ukrainians
using them yeah well i mean if they've
switched sides then they are they're
they're throwing their lot in with the
future of ukraine they'll certainly for
sure they'll never be able to go back to
russia while the putin regime is in
power and probably not there after
either so it's a big decision to take
but if you're faced with the likelihood
that you're going to get killed
then
there's a sort of balance of advantages
there and if somebody's going to offer
you money as well well why not okay
michael let's uh pause it there again
now you are watching a special question
and answer program on the war in ukraine
coming up next to nuclear weapons and
the potential of their use in this war
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back i'm with professor michael
clark and your questions about the war
in ukraine so uh let's plow on michael
uh this one is from darren darren's uh
concerned as so many people are of
course about nuclear weapons why have
nuclear weapons if the world is not
prepared to face the consequences
if they are used so uh what are they for
well uh deterrence is the word isn't it
yes i mean uh derma i've spent most of
my professional academic life thinking
about the consequences they are usually
used to do a lot of work on it at one
time and the one thing about nuclear
weapons lawrence friedman uh so lawrence
friedman great mentor of mine great
friend he has a great phrase about it he
says
that nuclear weapons and deterrence
works better in practice than it does in
theory because the theory is terrible
the theory just it falls apart every
time you poke it but he says but it
works in practice because actually
everybody gets frightened everybody
worries and the reason is because we
know what nuclear weapons do we don't
really know what chemical weapons do we
we've seen bits we've no idea what cyber
warfare does we don't really know what
conventional warfare is like i mean look
at the russians now i mean you know
they've confounded everybody's
predictions with their incompetence but
we know what nuclear weapons do we know
that if they are used certain
destruction will take place now i have
to say that one thing nuclear weapons
are not as delicate as people think it's
not like an egg that you've got to hold
for 50 years most nuclear devices are
more likely not to work than to work
because the triggering is so delicate
but assuming that they work
we know what they do so to give you some
comparisons the the beirut explosion in
2020 august 2020 remember remember the
big explosion in the dockside of beirut
which is a fertilizer factory that was
about 1.1
um uh k 1.1
uh uh kilotons which is a thousand tons
of tnt the hiroshima and nagasaki
exposed were about 15 kilotons
so use that as a
you know 15 times beirut is a nagasaki
or a hiroshima
a one megaton weapon
is about um
six times uh sorry 60 times uh a uh
a uh
uh uh hiroshima right and the sort of
weapons that are targeted at western
cities or that we target at eastern
cities are between two and five megatons
so you're talking about something like
300 times hiroshima
now that's unimaginable
unimaginable and the fact is that we
know that if they were used that's what
they would do
and although that is shocking it also
goes back to the idea that nuclear
deterrence works better in practice than
it does in theory and just in terms of
what we've heard from russia of course
it was
russia that raised the whole potential
use of them dmitry peskov the
president president putin's
spokesman seem to de-escalate that yes
because this is this is the point this
is this is not a nuclear crisis this is
a crisis about territory and about
ukraine although the russians keep
putin keeps trying to raise the nuclear
specter to frighten everybody it's very
hard to see that this is going to go
down a nuclear route i mean i know
everyone worries about it and they
should worry about it for the reasons
that i've mentioned but it's very hard
to see a nuclear
route emerging from the way this crisis
is likely to go okay another question
this is from bogdan uh and this is about
um
the dangers of the war spreading what
will the west do if belarus attacks
ukraine will nato get involved directly
against belarus we know that the
russians are running short of forces so
we know how close an ally uh the
belarusian leadership is
of uh russia could belarus get involved
well they already are because if you
look at the statements coming out of the
nato summit the eu summit in the g7
summit that was held at the weekend
very interestingly all those communiques
talked about russia and belarus it
talked about putin and lukashenka and so
because the the invasion was launched
from belarus and belarus is actively
helping the belarusians have not yet
sent troops into into ukraine although
they've threatened to and they may or
they may not but interestingly the west
is making it very clear that this crisis
has been caused by russia and belarus by
putin and lukashenka and so in a sense
lukashenk has put himself in the dock of
world opinion alongside putin and his
fate i'm fairly sure whatever putin's
fate is that would be looking i mean
couldn't it put luka shankar in some
trouble we know about the huge unrest
that
greeted his uh illegal victory in uh the
election a couple of years back we also
hear some talk of belarusian forces
forces of irregulars joining crossing
the border to join the ukrainians to
fight the russians they've got their
special forces and they and
a lot of belarusians are very unhappy
about this and there is a degree of
mutiny
in some of the belarusian forces i don't
think it'll make a big a particularly
big difference but it can't be pleasing
to the russians if that is the case and
i and i think you know if putin falls
because of this which i'm certain that
he will whether in the next two months
or the next three years but as and when
putin falls lukashenko falls as well
probably the following day in my view
okay len's got a question which is a
dimension of any peace deal or
settlement who's going to pay for the
rebuilding of ukraine will russia have
to pay for any of the reconstruction and
that brings us into the whole issue of
reparations and then how much that
rankles for generations to come and
the transition from the first world war
to the second world war but i mean
billions upon billions of dollars worth
of damage have been done to ukraine
yes and the world bank is already
talking now about the need for a new
marshall plan everyone says marshall
plan when they get to these stages
without realizing what the special
characteristics of the marshall plan
really were it's very lucky that the
marshall plan worked the way it did but
the world bank is now talking about what
will it take well we don't know until we
see what destruction has taken place by
the end of the war and how long it lasts
but there is a commitment among in the
western world to do all it takes for
political reasons and moral and ethical
reasons to rebuild ukraine and so it
will cost and it will cost all of us but
will it cost russia probably not i mean
you know part of the peace deal was well
you've got to front up 100 billion at
the very least to help rebuild it i i
i would love that to be true but i don't
think it will be because when it comes
to it when this war is over
depending on how long it lasts i think
russia will be on its knees if putin
stays in power for two or three years
with these sort of sanctions on and his
sort of of bone-headed
inflexible policy i think russia will be
on its knees and i think we'll just have
to swallow hard and say that russia's
not going to pay much for this but the
rest of us will well that leads straight
into doug's question uh sentine says
does a potential peace deal mean then
that president putin actually gets away
in some way shape or form with this war
you know this issue of payments and and
indeed any territory that they may hold
on to yes uh i mean i think the west is
very determined that the russians should
not be rewarded with even more territory
than that which they stole and took in
2014. and zielinski because he's very
good to say he's very clever he's out
he's out fox and putin all the time he's
now saying of course we can talk about
certain things and i think in his own
mind zelinski's probably thought i'll
never we'll never get crimea back
because that is basically 90 russian and
he's happy to be part of russia but i
think he's saying that actually we want
the donbass back you know a you've got
to get out of all the territories you've
taken since february the 24th and
incidentally you know we want we want
the donbass back and i think he feels
he's in a position to drive quite a hard
bargain my own view and i'm just
guessing now is that he would trade
crimea which would would not be happy
back with ukraine for everything else
that the russians have taken that's a
big big step for putin to take because
that would represent a war that wasn't
not only did he not win but left him
worse off than before in terms of his
historic mission to colonize ukraine and
that would provide um that makes the
metaphors so what's been mentioned
during all these um discussions about
the the way out for putin the the golden
bridge the the awful phrase the off ramp
yeah i i don't know where it would be to
be honest i don't know what what it
would be and unless he is somehow
rewarded with territory and the point is
that i think the west is saying look if
the ukrainians say that that's what they
will accept then we'll back them to say
that even through gritty teeth we don't
want them to say that but if that's what
they say they're the ones who are
fighting and dying we'll back it but if
the ukrainians say no you've got to get
out of the territory you've taken now
and out of the territory you took in
2014 then we'll back that as well and
the only i mean this is not a
particularly good answer but it's the
only one i can come up with at the
moment that the uh the western world has
got to back the judgment of the
ukrainian government because they're the
ones who are making sacrifices just a
very interesting point just to throw in
there before we've got to take a take
another break um president zielinski
mentioning in his statement was at the
weekend wasn't it uh you know addressing
putin addressing the russians saying
well you know what i'm talking about you
better go for yeah because there's a
younger generation behind me who are
fighting this war and they're not going
to be as accommodating yeah that's right
he was born in 1978 so he's only 44. and
he said to these russian journalists he
said i will be replaced by somebody
younger and less flexible than me
which is brilliant again because he's
saying you take a deal now while you can
it shows how much um i don't say he's
cocky but he's got confidence now
because his army and his people have
given him that strength to say look um
you know i can negotiate a better deal
now and the russians are getting their
positions getting harder and harder so
he's pushing really hard he's much for a
comedy actor oh my god he's tough he's
got he's got a core of steel yeah he's
certainly got his head around diplomacy
very quickly uh michael stay with us
you're watching a special question and
answer program on the war in ukraine
next uh we're asking more about nato and
how useful the united nations actually
is
hello
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet
if they do they fear they'll be killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
traffic jams snake for hours up and down
this hillside it means pressure day you
can't access those and knees
[Music]
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been
foreign see fires all around us here and
just one of them is the size of around
31 000 football pitches
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
welcome back you're watching sky news
and i'm with professor michael clark and
your questions about the war in ukraine
well uh let's see what joe has asked joe
wants to know is it time to reform the
united nations security council and
rethink the five permanent members so
well this is how hamstrung the un has
been in not just in this crisis but in
so many because of the the configuration
of the permanent members of the security
council yes this veto that any one of
them has that's right yeah there are 15
members 10 of them rotate and five of
them are permanent and they have a veto
so if any one of them says it can't
happen then it can't happen and those
five are america russia china britain
and france and that reflects the way
power was when it was set up in 1945.
of course it's ridiculous in one respect
that britain and france are still
permanent members i mean what about
brazil what about india what about you
know bigger countries what about a
european seat to substitute for what
britain france do um two things about
that one is that britain and france
because they're permanent members and in
a way what the world has moved on but it
does make them very good u.n members i
mean britain and france are always
trying to prove to the other members
that they're worth having on the
security council so they both of them i
think britain's got a good story to tell
here is very constructive we really do
try to be constructive in the un and by
and large our efforts or the efforts of
the british government over the years
have been well appreciated so you know
we work harder because we don't really
we don't really deserve the seat anymore
but the second thing is britain is
funnily in favor
completely in favor of a reform of this
of the security council permanent
membership we're totally in favor
because it won't ever happen
and so we actually we actually say yes
of course i mean and anyone who likes to
come up with a with a deal anyone who
wants to come up with the scheme you
know is welcome to try because the
brazilians are in there the indians are
in there i mean everybody is desperate
once you lift the lid on security
council members you'll never get
agreement there won't be a permanent
membership i mean it would be quite easy
to do it along the lines which you're
proposing there enlarge it and go to
majority voting well there's there's
lessons here from the european union you
could go to weighted voting so you could
say yes we'll have 15 members and we'll
wait their votes
so that
um any one of the major powers could be
outvoted two of the major powers
couldn't you could you could argue but
any one of them if it was an obstructive
power one of them would however to have
that that deal done the security council
would have to agree so to catch 22. you
know
russia and china for sure would not
agree and britain and france are all in
favor of it because it won't happen okay
we've got another question on nato a
slightly different angle from isabel
given the west new ukraine could be
invaded by russia why did nato not speed
up the process of accepting ukraine into
the alliance and this is the the
question that we can now never answer if
if that had happened and there were nato
troops sitting on ukrainian territory
would the russians have dared to attack
the argument against that isabel is that
if if ukraine had come into the alliance
the russians would have attacked earlier
the the one thing that the russians
would not have lived with ever
is ukraine or georgia coming into the
nato alliance i mean nato
has enlarged itself since 1949 when it
was founded it's enlarged itself nine
times nine times and six of those times
are since putin has been in power and
what he sees remember he's a very 19th
century politician he sees politics as a
map with colours on it like the old
imperialist maps and what he sees is
that nato's boundaries are now a
thousand miles closer to moscow than
they were a thousand miles and if
ukraine which is to his south and
georgia which is in some ways even
closer if they had come into nato he
would not have he would have gone to war
with europe about that
nato's mistake was not enlarging because
everybody wanted to come into nato nato
didn't try to enlarge it it was
demand-led everybody wanted to be in
nato they wanted to get into nato to get
the american security guarantee they
wanted to get into the eu to get the
prosperity of the european union and so
nato handled the enlargement process and
did quite a good job in its way but my
criticism of nato which goes back to
2008 is that we were nato was very blase
about making statements about eventual
ukrainian and georgian membership and i
said at the time on a few media programs
i thought this would be very eventual
you know this is this is so eventually
do you think that i mean that strategy
of keeping them in limbo was wrong if
you're going to do it do it yeah if not
if not be realistic i just say look you
you'll never come into nato because it
will be destabilizing nato is all about
stability and remember too that nato is
30 nations now it's the greatest
alliance the world has ever seen barn on
and it's still the greatest alliance the
world has ever seen but when it was 15
and then 16 nations it was very strong
now there's 30 nations it's a lot less
strong because it's got much longer
boundaries to defend and a bigger
problem in arriving at unanimity and so
in the last couple of of years last few
years we've taken in the military might
of montenegro and the last member the
30th member was the military giant of
north macedonia and all that gives us is
more problems of agreement more problems
of consensus not being rude to the north
macedonians um and no um corresponding
military benefit and so nato is now
struggling with 30 members to be really
meaningful having said which i go back
to what i said first it is still the
most impressive alliance the world has
ever seen and this crisis
was either going to give nato a shot in
the head or a shot in the arm and it's
actually giving it a shot in the head
shot in the eye wow
yeah let me glad you got that
very good here i think we got time to
squeeze in one more question uh michael
this comes from nick
again on nato regardless of the outcome
of the war will nato and russia have to
sit down and reassess past treaties
perhaps look at more appropriate
agreements following on from any deal
between ukraine and russia will will
nato and russia have to have some
grown-up discussions
they will but it will have to be in new
russia it'll have to be a post-putin
russia right because as we've said um
the russians crossed the boundary um
when this invasion took place they they
are it's you know putin is now beyond
the pale and we've we've tolerated too
much of this before in 2008 and then
2014 and now
and look at what the rest of the world
is doing china will not condemn this
india will not condemn it pakistan will
not condemn it brazil will not condemn
what putin has done and the whole of
africa
will not join in sanctions so the rest
of the world is waiting to see who
prevails and the africans i mean african
governments and
diplomats in africa they say this is
your war not ours um this is your
problem and actually from our point of
view in africa we're faced with the the
dominance of dictators or the dominance
of hypocrites we don't care who wins
dictators are hypocrites all the same to
us
so in fact
what is at stake is not just the war in
ukraine but a fundamental challenge to
liberal democracy so my view is that
this is not just a crisis to be managed
this is a challenge to the western
liberal order to our freedom which we in
which we have to prevail we haven't got
to manage it we've got to prevail
politically in all of this which means
that any any assumptions and any
discussions we have with russia in the
future has got to be a new europe and a
new russia
new russia without putin without putin
michael clark
fascinating as ever thank you so so much
for for joining us to share your
expertise and answer all those questions
from our viewers professor michael clark
we've got time now for a quick look at
the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well this north wind is going to make it
even colder over the next few days and
will bring some snow mainly on hills
many places are dry this evening but the
north of britain should have some
outbreaks of rain and that snow on
scottish hills in particular the wintry
mix spreading into central britain and
the north of ireland overnight some snow
showers will spread into scotland it'll
be frosty with some icy stretches
further south
probably dry with maybe some fog around
in parts of the southwest because it's
clearer showery rain and hill snow over
central areas then moving southwards
tomorrow morning
clearing the north of ireland around
about lunchtime depending when you have
your lunch the southwest then holding on
to some brightness but a few sharp
showers developing there
meanwhile
scotland will see some sunny spells and
wintry showers it'll feel much colder
than recently for most areas especially
in that wind the afternoon then will be
sunny for more parts of the north but
wintry showers over scotland will extend
into the northeast of england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and you're watching sky news coming up
in the next now more on ukraine
[Music]
you